[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
avec Frédéric bbé pour le Dictionnaire
amoureux des écrivains français
d'aujourd'hui le voici le voilà chez
plomb photo de dos un petit peu Frédéric
bonjour comme mais Davis il jouit contre
son public c'est ça exactement
écoutez ça compense avec le précédent
puisque côé pile voilà le côté pile et
le côté face mais vous avez votre main
sur ma tête et ça me fait du bien
Frédéric il s'agit d'un dictionnaire
amoureux des écrivains français
aujourd'hui à peu près 300 signatures je
le disais c'est publié chez plomb vous
expliquez au départ qu'au fond dans la
famille bbéd il n'y avait absolument
aucune chance que vous deveniez
romancier et que c'est donc c'est une
famille que vous vous êtes créé celle de
ceux qui sont là oui c'est vrai en
commençant par lire très tôt et écrire
aussi après le divorce de mes parents je
me suis mis à prendre des notes et à et
à entrer dans ce dans ce monde qui nous
entoure de ces livres qui qui sont en
fait des voix des voix réelles alors
c'est le plus souvent ce sont des morts
et là j'ai voulu faire un livre où il
n'y ait que des gens envie pour
l'instant ça marche toujours ils sont
ils sont toujours vivant voilà mais
c'est le contraire de l'éducation
nationale en fait quand on est au lycée
o à l'école c'est Molière Racine oui
c'est important aussi c'est important
aussi mais c'est vrai que c'est la nuit
des morts vivants la L ature on vous
enseigne quand même toujours des gens
qui sont décédés et et et là c'est une
famille de gens vivants qu'on peut
côtoyer avec qui on peut se disputer et
j'aime beaucoup la littérature
contemporaine je crois qu'en France elle
est en ce moment probablement une des
meilleures au monde c'est extrêmement
riche il y a de tout j'ai voulu créer
aussi des des familles créer des des
petits logos pour que chaque mouvement
littéraire soit bien identifié et c'est
c'est comme une jungle que j'explore
depuis 35 ans VO voilà à la fois comme
critique et évidemment comme auteur
alors je vais vous donner quelques idées
euh justement de ces écoles littéraires
défin par Frédéric bbé les américanisés
on peut trouver par exemple Olivier Adam
ou Philippe Dian les apôtres du bonheur
par exemple F kinos le flou artistique
une catégorie qui existe avec par
exemple Nina Bouraoui les gloques ou les
gloquistes apocalyptiques avec Giuliano
daomolis dont on a beaucoup parlé
l'année dernière où évidemment Virginie
dépense et puis il y a et on va
commencer par ça puisqu'il y aura trois
parties dans cette émission à la fois
les grands écrivains français vivants
d'aujourd'hui ceux qui sont les plus
contestés et ceux qui ont le plus
souffert de la critique à ce propos il
est quand même notable puisque Frédéric
disait que la littérature française se
porte bien elle se porte bien aussi au
niveau mondial car nous avons eu trois
prix Nobel et dans le plus grand
écrivain français vous avez et vous les
avez sélectionné Emmanuel carer Jean
eschenau Michel Welbeck Pierre Michon
Patrick Modiano et Yasmina re une pièce
est actuellement donc joué au théâtre de
la Colline alors vous dites trois prix
Nobel c'est tout à fait juste vivant
parce qu'on en a 16 on est le pays qui a
le plus de Nobel de littérature plus que
l'Amérique et C voilà c'est nous allons
commencer donc par Patrick Modiano voici
ce qu'il avait dit donc le 10 octobre
2014 et après nous allons examiner le
codiano grand écrivain français car vous
verrez dans l'article consacré à Patrick
Modiano par Frédéric tout est par rose
me semble un peu un peu irel de parce
que je me rappelle des des souvenirs
d'enfance Swan Camu de de quand j'avais
oui je devais avoir 12 ans le Prix Nobel
ensite ça qui et puis d'autres même donc
ça me semble un peu irréel en fait
d'être confronté avec des gens que j'ai
admiré quand j'étais
adolescent voilà pour ce premier extrait
donc qui nous permet de donner un peu d'
autour de ce dictionnaire amour des
écrivains français Patrick Modiano vit
du côté de la place saintsulpice un
nouveau livre vient de sortir la
danseuse estce que vous écrivez depuis
le début de sa carrière place de
l'Étoile avec un héros qui est un juif
antisémite c'est que contrairement à ce
que raconte la plupart des gens qui
lisent Modiano un peu trop vite il
n'écrit pas le même livre non pas du
tout il a fait des livres très très
personnels très intimes comme un pédigré
remise de peine qui par son enfance
voilà et puis il y a eu Dora Bruder qui
est une enquête tout à fait de
nonfiction autour d'une d'une déportée
une fillette qui a été raflée et emmenée
à achwitz et assassiné donc du coup il y
a il y a cette il a plusieurs styles et
la danseuse appartient c'est vrai à son
style plus plus traditionnel de
promenade nocturnes dans Paris des
années 60 avec des personnages interlope
moi je je je considère oui que c'est
probablement le plus grand français
vivant actuel enfin dans la dans la dans
ce livre peut-être avec Welbeck et schn
comme vous avez dit mais mais mais c'est
c'est très intéressant ce qu'il dit lui
sur tout de suite il reçoit le Nobel la
première chose qu'il dit ah ça me
rappelle mon enfance c'est comme dans
tous ces livres il il est toujours resté
cet enfant abandonné égaré dont les
parents sont absents et et le père était
probablement Cabo enfin dans une version
qui est difficile oui il été arrêté puis
relâché rapidement donc probablement il
avait des bonnes relations euh au placés
mais oui et puis cette mère qui
s'occupait pas vraiment de lui qui était
pas très aimante qui était une actrice
et tout ça dans une période très trouble
et donc il n'a jamais vraiment quitté
cette enfance et et c'est ce qui crée
cette magie et cette émotion dans dans
c'est ce que vous appelez livre inst
style c'est que les gens dites-vous
c'est vrai que les livres de Modiano
vous considérez qu'ils sont comme
critiques inégau que ça reste le plus
grand écrivain français euh mais qu'il y
a quelque chose de déchirant dans cette
génération qui n'est pas la vôtre à
savoir qu'il s'interroge sur ce qui
s'est passé avant et bien évidemment
avant c'était la guerre et bien
évidemment c'est ce flou qu'on retrouve
dans le style de Modiano à savoir qu'on
fait les parents que s'est-il passé
exactement c'est évidemment ce qui
caractérise son œuvre il a un point
commun avec Marcel prou c'est de parler
du temps et et d'essayer de transformer
le passé en en féerie alors prou il
utilise des phrases nettement plus
longues Modiano c'est comme un
prou compress c'est voyez un prou
resserré il est important d'aborder
aussi parmi les 300 personnages à peu
près qui sont ici les gens qui sont
beaucoup plus contestés que les Patrick
Modiano je vais donneré des exemples
d'ailleurs vous ne vous privez pas
Édouard lev vous l'assassinz Éric renard
vous l'assassinz aussi en expliquant que
l'un est un obsédé de la plainte et
l'autre n Talou edard Louis pardon parir
lever oui euh c'est c'est là que le
concept de dictionnaire amoureux des
écrivain français d'aujourd'hui é un peu
particulier parce que oui dictionnaire
un mot ou dictionnaire qui aime bien
châti bien qui aime bien châti bien donc
il y a des moi je j'estime qu'il faut
que je fasse le portrait le plus
subjectif le plus intime possible donc
c'est bien le problème avec ce projet
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait pas de
livrees comme ça en fait il y a pas
vraiment eu de livres depuis une
soixantaine d'années qui s'intéresse
uniquement aux vivants uniquement à mes
à mes confrères et conur bah ça pose ce
problème c'est les goûts j'ai j'ai des
goûts il y a des il y a des j'aime mieux
les usard où j'aime mieux les stylistes
que que les exhibitionnistes
narcissiques mais en même temps j'aime
l'autobiographie aussi donc je pense
qu'il faut c'est très bien de parler de
soi à la première personne mais il faut
passer aussi par quand même un peu la
pudeur le filtre de le filtre je ne sais
pas de du style oui le style on sait pas
très bien ce que ça veut dire mais enfin
euh un peu d'humour un peu
d'autodérision beaucoup de pas
d'autoflagellation mais mais un peu
d'autodénigrement quoi comme le faisait
François nourricier enfin bon voilà
c'est mes goûts à moi je vrais vous
poser deux ou trois questions précises
concernant ceux qui appartiennent à la
catégorie justement le moins connu c'est
Pierre Michon etchna on le connaît Ravel
courir donc des grands livres d'chnaau
il a été récompensé par agoncour
pourquoi considérez-vous et comment
expliquer à ceux qui nous regardent que
pour vous Pierre Michon fait partie des
plus grands écrivains français moi
j'avais pas lu Pierre Michon je me suis
renseigné autour de moi et Marie-Hélène
Lafond qui qui a eu le prix renaudo il y
a 2 ans elle considère que Pierre Michon
est le saint patron des lettres
françaises il y a beaucoup d'écrivains
qui se réfèrent à lui comme le le plus
grand prosateur actuel bon Pierre Michon
a reçu le Grand Prix de la BNF la
Bibliothèque nationale de France il y a
pas très longtemps il est vraiment
consacré aujourd'hui alors je je me suis
je me j'ai ouvert les livres de Pierre
Michon que je connaissais pas on peut
trouver que c'est de la dentelle
précieuse c'est une écriture ça se passe
toujours dans la nature à la campagne il
raconte plusieurs fois la même histoire
d'amour d'un jeune homme qui qui qui est
fasciné par une jolie buraliste qui
s'appelle Yvon et qui qui est d'ailleurs
le prénom aussi de qu'il y a dans le
grand mô d'Alain Fournier donc c'est si
vous voulez une littérature qui est pas
spécialement parisienne hein c'est une
littérature vraiment rurale mais avec
oui une beauté impressionnante c'est
très impressionnant Michon et il y a
toute une école de que j'ai découverte à
l'occasion de ce livre Pierre bergouou
Marie-Hélène Lafond mais des écrivains
aussi comme Richard met qui est plus ou
moins cancelé qu'on ne qu'on ne voà plus
non mais les cancelés sont présents
d'ailleurs c'est une des catégorie avant
que nous abordions justement ce qu'on
peut considérer comme disons les
écrivains contestés fusentil les statuts
du Commandeur ou comme Annie Ernaud il
s'agit de marcdouar naab oui est euh
mais il est vomi mznef il y est il est
vomi m est il y est il est vomi non je
l'ai je il est enfin comment dire dire
moi je les vomis pas moi je consid ils
ont été très attaqués ah oui oui c'est
des auteurs qui sont même plus
publiables aujourd'hui ce sont des gens
qui ont disparu par leur faute ils ont
ils ont ils sont passés du côté obscur
du côté incorrect enfin ils sont devenus
soit fachau soit complètement
inadmissible enfin il un po criminel
quand même Gabriel mazneev donc c'est
c'est je voulais en parler on vous a
reproché de le défendre oui oui mais je
voulais je voulais en parler parce que
c'est des auteurs qui ont compté pour la
génération NAB était très à la mode il y
a 30 ans mznef était publié chez le plus
grand éditeur français donc c'est des
auteurs qui ont compter et qui
aujourd'hui sont effacés vous écrivez au
début et je parle évidemment de cette
phrase pour ceux qui nous regardent
depuis Céline on sait qu'une merde
humaine peut accoucher d'un chef-dœuvre
donc à partir du moment où on prend cet
axe oui pourquoi les écrivains sont-ils
canceller puisque justement céine est là
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord je
pense pas qu'il faille effacer euh
l'ordurerie de la littérature la
littérature les écrivains antisémites au
19e siècle oui alors c'est c'est c'est
horrible mais la littérature décrit doit
pouvoir décrire le mal voilà ça n'est
pas exclusif on peut aussi faire des
livres qui font du bien et il y en a
beaucoup dans mon livre mais la
littérature a quelque chose à voir avec
le mal aussi et cette exploration du mal
nous allons passer à une autre statue du
Commandeur il s'agit d' hernaud la place
les années donc toute une carrière qui a
été récompensé aussi par le prix Nobel
de littérature à un moment où l'on
pensait peut-être que Welbeck l'urait
mais c'est an Arnaud qui l'a emporté et
voici les quelques mots qu'elle a confié
vous savez que c'est un auteur à la fois
révéré et contesté contesté par une
partie de la critique et contesté aussi
pour ses positions politiques puisqu'on
sait que Modiano est très silencieux
alors qu'ierna défend ouvertement
Jean-Luc Mélanchon la voici lors
lorsqu'elle s'est exprimée récemment le
Nobel S imagine pas ou alors il faut
être un peu je complètement un peu
parjot quoi pour s'imaginer comme je
disais il faut avoir une prétention
absolument notez qu'il y en a qui n'en
manque pas mais ça jamais été mon
cas voilà dans le le la petite notule
d'ailleurs importante que vous lui
consacrez vous dites c'est le statut de
la commandeuse la pade pour bientôt elle
est déjà étudié par ma fille au lycée et
pourtant il y a une certaine forme de
réticence que vous exprimez car je le
dis dans ce dictionnaire on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure pour renard ou euh pour
éedouard Louis vous ne cachez pas non
plus un non bien sûr il y a un a priori
critique il y a beaucoup d'auteurs que
qui sont pas ma tasse de thé mais je les
ai mis quand ils étaient importants euh
Christine Ango constance Debré c'est les
auteurs que j'ai dont je me moque
régulièrement et en même temps je crois
qu'elles ont une importance et qu'elles
existent et que donc elles devaient
elles avaient leur place dans ce livre
Annie hernaud alors par-dessus tout
puisque Annie hernaud c'est celle qui a
influencé les auteurs que je viens de
citer qui Édouard Louis également donc
fille d'épiciier agrégé de lre
professeur comment peut-on dire je veux
dire obséder c'est unme un terme qui est
vilain par rapport à ce qu'elle a écrit
mais disons obséder par l'idée qu'il y a
au départ de tout la condition sociale
et c'est de ça dont il faut parler avec
une écriture la plus neutre possible de
ce point de vue là elle a quelque chose
en commun avec Welbeck alors qu'il sont
dans deux mondes différents et que à
travers cette écriture il faut essayer
de faire passer une émotion qui est
celle de toute une vie les années ou oui
de celle du père de celle de la mère de
celle de ses amours ratés de son mariage
raté la femme frigide par exemple
pourquoi est-elle importante elle a une
importance déjà formelle c'est ce que
vous disiez c'estàd cette sécheresse
cette phrase très très
minimale pour pour parler de de de sa
vie et d'exposer sa vie à la prem prière
personne la l'idée que la transfuge de
classe ne quitte jamais sa sa classe
d'origine et regarde le monde avec avec
une espèce de de de regard métallique et
très très froid et en même temps en
parlant d'obsession en parlant d'amour
en parlant de d'un viol qu'elle a subi
en parlant de son avortement donc ça a
été un écrivain qui a beaucoup agacé à
une époque qui est aujourd'hui très très
consacré peut-être même surestimé mais
là encore il y a des bons et il y a des
mauvais livres moi à mes yeux les années
est un livre important le dernier qui
s'appelle le jeunehomme bon c'est 30
pages sur une histoire vraiment très
très bon qui n'a pas qui n'a pas à mon
avis un grand intérêt mais ça c'est ce
n'est que mon avis moi je trouve quand
même qu'il fallait qu'elle a son
importance déjà par l'influence qu'elle
a eu éormément d'auteurs se réclame d'ny
hernaud et c'est vrai qu'elle a libéré
quelque chose une parole elle c'est vrai
qu'elle a libéré c'est d'ailleurs
généralement mieux de de lire l'original
que les copies au total une jeune fille
mal coiffée c'est une phrase que vous
citez dans le dictionnaire c'est une
phrase qui aurait pu dites-vous être
écrite par François Sagan et tout d'un
coup elle ajoute après je la sais dans
une solitude intrépide de son
intelligence et alors là vous dites
justement c'est là le paradoxe d'hernaud
c'est que c'est à la fois le talent
absolu mais en même temps une certaine
forme de de ridicule non avoué c'est
surtout le
commentaire c'est un bon exemple je
genre elle se décrit en disant je suis
une jeune fille mal coiffée c'est c'est
c'est charmant mais c'est le commentaire
de la phrase d'après qui est malheureux
on n pas besoin de dire je la sais dans
la solitude de son intelligence
intrépide en fait on se passerait
souvent de l'autosatisfaction d'I Ernaud
parce qu'elle a un réel talent
d'observation donc peut-être que elle a
elle a une elle a mis à nu sa sa
condition de femme mais pas assez à nu
peut-être qu'elle aurait fallu
quelquefois corriger encore plus il y a
énormément donc d'écrivains on parlait
d' yasminine arza de Daniel rondau le
roqueur académique c'est vrai qu'au
passage d'ailleurs là je tombe sur
Jean-Christophe Ruffin romancier du
passé comme du futur vous parlez aussi
de Marc Lambron vous avez eu une envie
d'académie française il y a beaucoup
d'académiciens français qu'on trouve
dans ce livre est-ce que c'est une façon
pour bbéd de rendre service à ceux qui
pourrai lui rendre service non soyez
franc je casse la table non non non je
je je considère qu'il y a quelques
écrivains à l'Académie française c'est
un miracle écoutez soyons heureux il y
en a quelques-uns et donc je et soyez
encore plus j'ai décidé d'en parler non
mais j'aime beaucoup je pense que
l'ambron a apporté quelque chose
l'impromptu de Madrid et les livres il
écrit quand il était donc à l'ambassade
comme attaché culturel sur ce qui s'est
passé après justement la
disparitionition de la dictature en esp
côté Paul Morand du palace qui qui qui a
qui a eu d'importance pour ma génération
après Ruffin c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant il algoncour pour un livre très
classique à la Alexandre Duma qui
s'appelle rouge Brésil et qui parle de
la l'éphémère colonisation du du Brésil
par les Français et puis après il fait
Globalia qui est un livre de
science-fiction dystopique très
ambitieux à la George Orwell donc le
passé comme le futur non c'est des
écrivains pour moi qui qui ont une
importance non moi je suis pas candidat
j'ai été candidat ils m'ont jeté on s'en
fout c'est pas très important c'est fini
je voulais faire plaisir à mon père et
il est plus là arrêtons-nous sur Welbeck
c'est le plus contesté c'est le plus lu
dans le monde c'est le plus grand pour
vous ou le plus traduit alors après euh
c'est la même chose qu'anierno pourquoi
quand un écrivain crée des polémiques et
des controverses ça veut dire qu'il a
quelque chose d'important qu' il a mis
le doigt sur quelque chose pour moi
parce qu'il a parce que à lui seul en
1998 quand il publie Les Particules
élémentaires à lui seul en un seul roman
il est il a remis la littérature
française euh au niveau mondial au
centre je dirais euh et en plus en
faisant quoi en faisant du Balzac
c'est-à-dire Welbeck presque à lui tout
seul mais il était pas vraiment tout
seul parce qu'il y avait quand même une
bande autour de lui d'écrivains post
naturaliste euh dont vous citez ravalc
mais il y a aussi Virginie despente
c'est ces écrivainsl ont remis la
narration romanesque au cœur de notre
littérature elle était partie un peu en
en vrille la littérature l'anticipation
oui avec cette espèce d'envie de faire
un livre global total un roman qui est
un miroir de notre temps comme disait
standandal mais lui aujourd'hui et le
nouveau roman qui avait été à la mode
des années 50 à 70 a été presque tué par
Welbeck tout seul alors les particuliers
élémentaires la carte et le territoire
plateforme possibilité du Nil sérotonine
je vrais simplement rappeler quelque
chose Frédéric concernant Frédéric bbé
Michel Welbeck les particules élémentair
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure je me
souviens de l'avoir reçu à à nulle part
ailleurs à l'époque on de revenir 100
ans en arrière avait critiqué le livre
de Welbeck dans l'ordre Bernard Pivot
Jérôme Garsin éic nollo François Bunel
pierre assouine c'est des gens qui
tiennent le haut du pavé de la critique
donc au fond il y a quand même l'erreur
est humaine c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire non mais la critique c'est bon
signe quand un livre se fait descendre
et il y avait quelque chose de très
provocateur chez Welbeck et quand quand
on provoque bah il y a des réactions
donc c'était bien je pense que c'était
bien que que ça soit écrivain scandaleux
et il avait cherché un peu il avait mis
des scènes échangistes il y avait des
choses il faisait l'éloge du clonage
c'était quand même très très très
dérangeant et tant mieux le le le enfin
ce que vous expliquez comme étant le
fondamental de son œuvre justement c'est
important dans un dictionnaire c'est ve
dire que Welbeck a compris que au fond
nous étions nous les occidentaux euh les
Occidentaux qui se déplacent en voyage
plateforme les Occidentaux qui
travaillent à l'Assemblée nationale
comme ce fut son cas dominé par quelque
chose qui est qui a été peu traité par
la littérature qui est la misère
sexuelle la littérature française alors
qu'on trouve ça évidemment dans la
littérature
américaine extrêmement souvent doncou
Liv les livres de Philip Ross par
exemple porort no et son
complexe serait aujourd'hui impubliable
question est-ce que vous considérez que
justement ces 300 écrivains ou presque
français sont au niveau de nos confrères
anglo-saxons russes alors moi je je j'ai
une théorie qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut je
trouve que la littérature anglo-saxonne
était nettement supérieure à la nôtre il
y a 20 ou 30 ans dans les années 90
c'était flagrant il y avait des des
auteurs sont apparus je veux dire
brtisonellis
jaminerne Tom Wolf et tout ça et ensuite
avec le politiquement correct la
littérature américaine et anglaise aussi
un peu sont en train de s'asceptiser il
y a de moins en moins de liberté chez
eux et chez nous la liberté est là chez
nous on est encore oui chez nous on a
encore la chance de pouvoir écrire ce
qu'on veut mais c'est pas ça ne veut pas
dire que ça va durer mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si on voit ce qui se
publie là dans la rentrée vous avez des
livres c'est une grande diversité des
livres choquants des livres ambitieux et
c'est plus le cas de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique euh je vrais citer un livre
de Scott fiterald dont on parle peu mais
qui est dans une collection qui ne coûte
pas très cher l'imaginaire galimar sont
des nouvelles tous les jeunes gens
tristes c'est un cheeduvre absolu et
souvent je me suis dit que le rêve de
Frédéric bebédé dont on ne sait pas s'il
sera un grand écrivain en tout cas il
fait des efforts et bien son modèle
c'est peut-être évidemment Scott fidiral
aije raison vous le basque ben disons la
la la le le point commun c'est des c'est
livresse c'est l'idée qu'on peut sortir
le soir et et écrire le lendemain matin
avec un fort mal de tête mais je c'est
la seule c'est là où la comparaison
s'arrête c'est que je ne suis pas et je
ne serai jamais Scott figérald est-ce
que vous êtes conscient comme les
ténourissers euh il acrit un très beau
livre sur ce thème qui s'appelle à
défaut Gén est-ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui à presque 60s
la conscience que vous êtes passé à côté
de ce que vous pourriez être Frédéric
bbédé a-t-il réussi son coup ou pas ah
c'est pas à moi de le dire soyez Fran
mais j'aime bien une phrase de Jules
Renard dans son journal où il dit il y a
les grands écrivains et il y a les bons
écrivains soyons les bons c'est c'est
pas c'est pas de la fausse modestie
c'est que moi parmi mes écrivains
préférés il y a des auteurs qui sont
considérés comme mineurs peut-être que
Scott vigerald était moins ambitieux
qu'emingway peut-être que
Patrick Modiano est moins ambitieux
qu'onoré de
Balzac et voilà aujourd'hui il y a il y
a Michel Welbeck qui est centrale mais
il y a aussi peut-être de la place pour
des petits auteurs j'aime beaucoup
Alfred de muset j'aime beaucoup Benjamin
Constant vous voyez c'est c'est des
écrivains qui ont fait des livres courts
qui parlaient d'un certain malaise avec
du charme et voilà de la petite musique
je vrais citer aussi parce que nous
vivons des temps terribles vous rendez
hommage par exemple à Philippe Lançon
vous dites la violence l'a rendu ou a
fait lui un grand écrivain ce n'était
pas forcément le cas au départ
évidemment on se souvient de l'attentat
de Charlie Hebdo et du Bataclan vous
parlez de Jonathan little avec Les
Bienveillantes consacré évidemment au
nazisme mais les carnets de Holms qui
est qui est un livre dont vous dites
qu'il est fondamental qui raconte
justement C cette expérience de Jonathan
littleou le nouveau little qui s'appelle
un endroit inconvénient qui est un titre
étrange et qui est consacré au mass
sacre de bcha en Ukraine voilà Brando
dans Apocalypse là vous le citez hor has
a face and you must make a friend of
horor donc vous devez faire une de
l'amitié ENF n en tout cas professer une
certaine forme d'amitié pour l'horreur
nous en savons quelque chose maintenant
dernier point le monde de l'édition le
monde de la critique vous êtes à la fois
critique littéraire au Figaro membre de
je littéraire le ronudo vous avez fondé
le flur vous êtes écrivain vous avez des
amis vous avez les ennemis et beaucoup
de gens considèrent que tout ça est un
mélange malsin d'ailleurs leclésio dans
le procès verbal écrivait ça j'imagine
qu'il va falloir passer sous peu devant
un tribunal d'homme je leur laisse ses
ordures en guise de testament voici donc
notre ami leclésio il reçu le Nobel 9
octobre
2008 il a quelques
minutes un peu plus d'une heure je crois
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone de
l'Académie Nobel qui me disait monsieur
nous vous annonçons que nous vous avons
décerné le Prix Nobel de littérature
j'ai dit bien je vous remercie comme
tous les prix littéraires c'est une
grande chance parce que le prix
littéraire ça ça donne le temps et ça
c'est un encouragement
et bon c'est à tout âge de la vie et qu
au bien c'est c'est bien de recevoir un
prix
littéraire voilà la beauté physique
extraordinaire il a plus de 80 ans
donc du procès verbal du chercheur d'or
de désert de de livres magnifiques mais
il vous est arrivé de les flinguer et
c'est là où on aborde la question de la
critique littéraire parce que vous avez
même dit qu'il était barbant bah ça
dépend des livres là encore c'est comme
Ernaud c'est comme tout le monde ça
dépend il y a des livres de de leclésio
qui sont un peu moralisateurs d'honneur
de leçon il a eu une phase où presque
tous ces livres racontaient la même
histoire en général d'une petite
migrante qui arrive d'Afrique et qui
arrive en Europe et qui souffre et sujet
important bien sûr mais enfin qui était
c'était un peu répétitif et en réalité
ce que je préfère chez leclésio c'est sa
curiosité ce sont ses voyages c'est ce
qu'il a écrit sur son père qui vivait en
Afrique il a à peine connu c'est ce
qu'il écrit sur l'Î Maurice sur ses
souenir à Nice enfin il a je pense qu'il
était peut-être meilleur dans
l'autobiographie que dans le le roman si
vous voulez le roman qui fait du bien
euh vous avez vu qu'il est conscient dès
le procès ver il a une vingtaine
d'années que le flingage l'attend c'est
que tous les écrivains sont condamnés à
quelque chose qui est la violence de la
critique de leur époque est-ce que
est-ce que cette critique est juste
est-ce qu'on est dans un monde
insesteux alors oui c'est un monde
inseseux bien sûr moi je suis critique
écrivain j'écris ce livre sur mes mes
amis sur mes ennemis mais je trouve que
justement ce qui était intéressant c'est
c'est de faire un livre impossible parce
que ce livre n'existait pas un un
écrivain qui parle de 300 de ses
collègues envie qui peuvent lui en
vouloir c'est c'est à la fois
inconscient un peu un un peu drôle un
peu bizarre c'est ça qui m'intéressait
et je je trouve que dans une époque où
les livres sont plus tellement au centre
de la société c'est bien de de créer
cette agitation c'est pour ça que depuis
mes débuts j'ai voulu faire des prix
littéraires des revu m'impliquer dans ce
milieu parce que c'est un milieu que en
fait comme vous l'avez dit en commençant
c'est moi c'est la famille que je me
suis trouvé je me suis créé une famille
et j'adore aller dans les salons du
livre et me disputer il y a des auteurs
qui refusent de me serrer la main il y a
des auteurs qui ont envie de me cracher
dessus de me me casser la gueule
d'autres avec qui je me je me saoule
avec plaisir et et même ce que je trouve
formidable c'est d'avoir aujourd'hui une
émission à la radio sur Radio Classique
où je peux inviter des gens que j'admire
mais aussi des gens que j'aime pas ou
qui ou qui m'aime pas et on en parle
voilà c'est ça l'avantage en fait de
s'intéresser au vivant oui dit au début
du livre
euh j'ai été cette espèce de de
chroniqueur mondain ce jeune homme
désespéré l'amour 3 ans et cetera et
maintenant quelque part aux alentours de
50 ans c'est je me suis rangé je suis
reparti du côté du roman français c'est
du côté de l'histoire de ma famille à
Guetari donc pas très loin de peau
qu'est-ce qui a changé parce que là vous
êtes très S c'est la vieillesse c'est ça
qui a changé c'est comme Patrick Besson
dont vous parlais à savoir que il y a un
moment quand on passe 50 ans on n plus
envie de voyager on est vieux non mais
peut-être qu'on retrouve on a besoin de
retrouver des racines d'aller à la
source de revenir comme comme Modiano
comme prus à l'enfance essayer de savoir
d'où on vient qui on est c'est tout
simple et puis à à 20 ans on on veut
changer le monde on on veut se révolter
peut-être qu'à vous vous avez été
trélite du Parti communiste en même
temps membre du cacass club en même
temps écrivain célébré par une
génération en même temps détesté par les
féministes en même temps éternellement
jeune d'alu en même temps vieillissant
famille parisien provincial vous avez
fait le portrait complet j'ai pas j'ai
rien à ajouter c'est je suis tout ça à
la fois et c'est ce qui ce qu'il y a de
génial c'est de pouvoir euh écrire avec
tout ça avec tout ce bordel qui est une
vie humaine voilà et les contradictions
qu'on a évidemment vouloir changer le
monde j'ai toujours envie de changer le
monde je pense pas que le monde soit
merveilleux et en même temps avec l'âge
on a on a aussi envie de sauver quelques
quelques valeurs quelques petites choses
et ça ça fait qu'on devient pour
certains un vieux con dernier point il
est important la vie sans leshéros ne
fonctionne pas c'est la base du
romanesque il compris d'ailleurs chez
les écrivains qui sont les écrivains du
nouveau roman il y avait des héros chez
les écrivains du Nouveau Roman le livre
absolu pour Frédéric bbéé alors là on
entre dans la catégorie de ceux qui ne
sont peut-être plus là ah bah l'auteur
absol le livre absolu je dirais c'est
l'Évangile parce que c'est une histoire
complètement dingue c'est une histoire
dingue un type qui arrive déjà il a il a
pas de père enfin on sait pas puis il se
trouve que son père c'est peut-être Dieu
et christop Petitfils quand il dit des
choses assez simples il dit des choses
assez belles aimez-vous les uns les
autres et tout et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on le crucifie et puis il meurt et 3
jours après il ressuscite bon c'est une
histoire démente c'est une histoire
complètement qui rend tout le monde
dingue de depuis 2000 ans mais mais la
question c'est est-ce que c'est une
fiction ou est-ce que c'est la vérité je
vousis citer simplement pour terminer en
remerciant Frédéric bebéé d'être venu
puisqu'il prendra probablement ma place
bientôt ici pour présenter cette
émission je me souviens d'ailleurs qu'il
a présenté une émission littéraire qui
s'appelait enfin beaucoupreo non d'abord
délivrez-vous et puis vous avez aussi
fait le le Gai Savoir ou des
striptiseuse venez lire des extraits et
vous étiez tous nus si ma mémoire est
bonne et ça se passait dans un endroit
qui nétait pas lo être une sorte de
bordel voici beaucoup plus sérieusement
et ce qui se passe à l'est deeurope la
plaisanterie de Kundera qui est dans
folio et nous avons parlé tout à l'heure
de carnet de homes de Jonathon little ce
qui évoque évidemment ce qui se passe
actuellement et qui est malheureusement
tragique merci Frédéric d'être venu on
se retrouve bientôt
[Musique]
Ciao
[Applaudissements]